well there is this other story that I
heard about when you were doing is it
bosia when you when you was it David
Bowie yeah what in the world this story
is incredible to me like there's so much
to this story so you met him with basat
right I did that was uh that was a a
photo shoot that we did when we were
promoting the film but the first time
that I met him and he meant the world to
me and I there were periods in my life
where his music was a soundtrack I mean
he was just he is a soundtrack you know
on so um I had the chance uh to paint
for about 6 months before uh filming
began Julian schneble who directed the
film allowed me access to a studio and I
would be in there painting sometimes
there would be 20 bosot you know real uh
pieces of his work lined up and I would
take a bit from one and a bit from
another and just try to try to make
myself comfortable with his aesthetic
and his style and also with the act of
painting yeah had you ever painted
before that um little little bit a
little bit not not not as much as I had
then yeah as I did then but I uh so I'm
down on my you know on this canvas one
day and the door opens and in walks
David Bowie sure CU he's playing he's
going to play uh Andy Warhol in the
movie and he walks in and I'm down there
and he kneels down next to me and he
says uh he says do you mind if I watch
and I said well uh I think I'm going to
have to get used to it yeah so uh but
like absolutely not says my soul Terri
and we but we had to laugh at that you
know and and from then on I mean he was
just so generous and so smart and funny
and I mean he couldn't have been cooler
to me I remember one day we were in the
hair and makeup trailer Gary Oldman was
in the uh the the film as well we're
sitting there and David walks in he goes
right you see you you want to hear some
music and we're like huh like his music
like his his music like yeah David Bowie
will tolerate your music here yeah sure
put in your little disc there and and so
he puts in his new album that has not
come out yet and it's an album called
outside some of the music is featured in
the film because it's kind of
reminiscent of the story in some ways
and he uh his his guitarist was named
Reeves gabell and he plays this really
abstracted beautiful stuff and we're
listening to it we're like whoa and
David's sitting there air guitaring to
his own
mus and it was like it was like you know
the cool guy at school who found some
who found some obscure record somewhere
and brought it in except the cool guy
was David Bowie that was like amazing it
was like I love that
[Music]
[Applause]
story
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home